what up space cowboy goes in here for
anime uproar and because of the awesome
feedback on the first best geniuses in
anime I'm doing a number two I always
plan for this to be an ongoing series so
if you guys want to see more
installments make sure to smash that
like button and let me know what
geniuses you would like to see in the
next one I will do something I don't
usually do and give myself a deadline I
will release part three within a week of
this video hitting 4000 likes so if you
guys want to see part three make sure we
get to 4,000 likes and if we don't hit
it I don't have to worry about hustling
my butt off to get it out also if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and ring
that notification bell so you don't miss
any new videos remember these videos
aren't in any particular order so don't
get salty if your favorite genius hasn't
been featured yet also keep in mind that
these are entertaining geniuses who
demonstrate their intellect and
interesting even mind-blowing ways so I
don't want to hear people saying that I
forgot to mention some character with a
super high IQ but who hasn't use it for
anything other than doing well in school
there will be some anime spoilers in
this video but I won't go into manga or
light novel spoilers so never fear on
that account now without further ado
let's jump into it first off as promised
in the last video I'm going to be
talking about El from Death Note along
with Lelouch L is one of my all-time
favorite characters in anime he is not
just number one detective in the world
which would be impressive on its own he
also created two fictional detectives he
solved some cases under their names and
developed their reputation so that they
are considered to be the second and
third best detectives in the world
imagine being the first second and third
best something in the world I don't
think there's a bigger flex than that
it's like if novak djokovic the number
one tennis player in the world had the
time to impersonate two other tennis
players he enters sometimes tournaments
with disguises and those two made up
tennis players would rise up to second
and third place so while everyone else
is focusing all of their efforts on
advancing themselves up the rankings
he'd be splitting his effort between
three different player names and all
three would be stunting on everyone else
that might help but else insane level of
genius
into perspective for you now let's turn
to the second episode I always used to
say that you should know if an anime is
worth watching after the first two
episodes I started saying this because
anime like Clannad and Death Note had me
hooked by the end of the second episode
for Clannad the moment where Nagi says
waiting in the rain for Tamiya because
they said they would play basketball was
just so beautiful to me that I knew I
was watching something special
similarly in Death Note I was hooked by
the second episode and it was all thanks
to Elle up to this point in the anime
light was going on a killing spree with
the Death Note he got it he tested it
he had his obligatory oh no I'm a
monster what have I done moment then he
got over it and decided he would be the
god of the new world he's a genius he's
cautious and careful he's disciplined
he's driven he seems to have everything
completely under control
he's well on his way to making his dream
come true then all of a sudden enter L
wild light is kicking back in watching
some TV there's suddenly an interruption
it's a worldwide broadcast from the
International Criminal Police
organization Lind L tailor aka the
famous detective L has revealed himself
to the world he speaks almost directly
to light he says that the success of
murdering of criminals that light's been
doing with the Death Note is
unforgivable and will be punished he
promises to find Kira which is the name
that the public has given light light
from the other side of the TV screen
calls him a fool he says L will never
catch him it's impossible at first light
is relatively chill about the whole
thing he expected the police to get
involved after all but L clearly has a
gift for criminal profiling based on the
crimes l can get a sense of the
offender's psychological and behavioral
characteristics he understands life's
motivations
he knows the light sees himself as being
good and being on the side of justice
after walking around and feeling he's
smart and everyone his whole life
someone finally seems to be seeing
through light then L takes advantage of
lights personality and calls him evil
the single worst thing you can call
light because he views himself as a God
of justice trying to rid the world of
evil light hates evil and L knows this
light completely loses his composure he
starts defending himself to himself
saying he's justice he saves the weak
from evil
he will be the God that creates a world
that everyone desires and the ones who
try to cross God are the true evil ones
l baited him and life fell for it hook
line and sinker he reaches for the death
note he says and I quote I can't believe
that you're this stupid L this could
have been fun if you'd been a little
smarter and quote now light usually
writes the name small and very neatly in
the death notes he doesn't want to waste
more space than necessary
he's usually cold and calculating but he
writes Lind L tailor shame in absolutely
huge letters that take up about 1/3 of
the page this is further proof that L
has successfully gotten into light's
head they usually careful cold and
calculating light was manipulated into
completely losing his cool in doing
something he would never usually do when
Lind L tailor dies of a heart attack
light is ecstatic he laughs and asks
what's the matter now what do you have
to say this is when the real L makes his
appearance right when light is most
certain of his victory and superiority
ELLs logo appears on the screen and we
hear his real but filtered voice Lind L
tailor wasn't inmate whose execution was
scheduled for that day the police
arrested him in secrecy so light
wouldn't have heard about him through TV
or the Internet L points out that not
even kita has access to these types of
criminals I'll use this inmate perfectly
to figure out vital information about
kita he confirmed that kita can kill
with a name and a face without being
present but he also proved that kita
isn't a God since he showed that he is
not omniscient if he was truly an
all-powerful unbeatable God he would
have known that this was a fake L thus
in a matter of moments L tricked light
into taking action he got useful
information he proved that kita existed
and he proves to everyone watching that
he's not really an all-powerful god of
justice but a man who can be opposed he
goes on to taunt light
he tells kita to try and kill him
knowing that kita probably can't do it
without his face and name he even tells
him to hurry up l just stunted on light
he made someone who looked like an
all-powerful God a moment ago
completely powerless and the best part
is he's not even done yet you see even
though light was told that this was a
worldwide broadcast it wasn't it was
only shown to one region in a few
minutes
l tricked light into revealing that he
is in the Kanto region of Japan he just
narrowed Kira's possible whereabouts
from anywhere in the world to a specific
region in one country although death nah
wasn't published in 2019 I will use
current population numbers just to give
you a sense of how much L narrowed his
search down in a matter of moments the
current population of the world is
around seven point seven billion people
the population of the Kanto region is
around forty 3.5 million if my
calculations are right I'll just cut
down the list of possible suspects by
almost 99.5 percent so how did L know to
start where he did well remember that
random kidnapper like killed to test the
death on in episode 1
you and me might have already forgot
about that but not L L notice that the
kidnapper was one of the first criminals
to die suddenly of a heart attack and
that his crimes were by far the least
serious his crime was also only ever
reported inside Japan thus L deduced
from this information that Kira is in
Japan and that his first killing was
little more than an experiment they did
the broadcast in Kanto first because of
its large population and they found kita
has a little cherry on top of the cake L
even tells light that he never expected
things would go this well so not only
did L outsmart Kira here he even
suggests that he overestimated him in
other words he's telling light the dude
with a god complex rather than just a
superiority complex that he is even
stupider than L expected him to be not
only is L not intimidated by Kira and
his powers he even confidently proclaims
that it won't be too long until he
catches Kira and sentences him to death
l disconnects and we almost get 10 whole
seconds of light being speechless this
silence starkly contrasts the
uncontrollable laughter we got just a
few moments ago when light thought he
beat L this is my favourite character
introduction in all of anime and in
large part it is due to the fact
Elle is able to completely flip the
script in just a few minutes Elle's
intelligence allows him to make light
who has been portrayed as an
extraordinary genius up to this point
looks stupid light seemed like he was so
cautious and rational but L makes him
lose his cool and do something dumb kita
seemed all-powerful and all-knowing
before but L makes kita look weak kita
seemed like a god of justice to many
people but L makes him look like an evil
criminal l goes on to have many more
epic detective moments he figures out
that light is a student and he is
connected to the police and so on and so
on but it is this first moment that
always stands out to me it absolutely
blew my mind like nothing ever did
before or since I was hooked and to this
day I still hold it against my friends
when I show them the first two episodes
of Death Note and they don't go on to
watch the rest of the series like what
are you thinking man next I want to talk
about Sora from no game no life
I love no game no life and I mainly
watch this anime because you guys
suggested it in the last video so thank
you that is one of the benefits of being
an anime youtuber you get constant
recommendations
now for the Shiro fans yes maybe Sora's
not as intelligent as his sister when it
comes to mathematical calculations but
he's entertaining AF and he's better at
thinking outside the box
for instance Shiro is better at chess
but she has trouble in Episode three you
and the pieces stop obeying her commands
however sora figures out how to adapt to
the situation despite now using magic he
finds a way to defeat the cheating
kutami he uses his charisma to get the
enemy queen on his side which in turn
leads to its victory
what's even more hilarious is that he
used his experience with dating
simulation games to win a chess match he
didn't keep trying to follow the rules
of chess rather he adjusted to the
circumstances and beat Kaname at her own
game even though she was cheating with
elf magic then there is the coin flip
arguably the best example of outside the
box thinking Sora plays a game against
the eastern Federation leader it seems
pretty straightforward she just has to
call heads or tails and get it right it
seems like she has a 50/50 chance it
will either be heads or
however because of her special talents
the Eastern Federation leader can
predict the trajectory of the coin so
she knows what the outcome is going to
be at this point it seems like the 50-50
chance just shot up to 100% and if we
are thinking inside the box that's
completely correct but the whole time
Sora was thinking outside the box
he created the illusion that there were
only two possible outcomes but in fact
there was a third as the coin is about
to hit the ground sora moves a floor
tile so that the coin lands on its edge
a completely unpredictable outcome if
you're thinking inside the box the coin
flip game itself ends with a tie but in
reality Sora won and got exactly what he
wanted he made it a win-win situation he
allowed the Eastern Federation leader to
say faced by not beating her and
illustrated his gaming skills at the
same time the single most important
attribute you can have in their world
obviously the Eastern Federation leader
knows that she doesn't want to make
enemies with someone who is so good at
games in this world where games decide
everything and she doesn't have any
resistance because Sora presents his
wish in such an appealing way and makes
it feel like it's the Eastern Federation
leaders choice if he just beat her and
forced her to follow his orders he could
have antagonize the leader and her
people but by framing it as a choice
everyone is going to feel like they are
in it together and they'll be more loyal
as a result thus once again Sora used
his charisma just as he did with the
enemy Queen in Episode three to get what
he wanted by convincing someone else
that it's what they want as well and so
this seeming tie with a coin flip is in
fact the best possible way to ensure the
actual win Sora wanted again Sora
illustrates how you always have to keep
the bigger picture a Kade the larger
game in mind rather than just the mini
game in front of you next I want to talk
about the mad genius himself sanku from
dr. stone in the last genius video
everyone was like where is sanku so here
he is every single episode of dr. stone
is full of sanku using his mind and
scientific knowledge to do amazing
things
who knew exactly what year and day it
was when he came out of the rock how did
he know this he counted the seconds that
passed by for over 3,700 years and they
converted those seconds into years and
days and he even did this while thinking
about other things why did he need to do
all that counting
well besides flexing his brainpower and
discipline mind he did it so he'd know
when it was spring since if he woke up
in winter being naked and without food
it would have immediately been game over
even though something so ridiculous
happened like everyone on the planet
turned into stone Zankou managed to keep
his cool and logically think about the
situation from the very first second as
a stone statue he kept his mind focused
for over 3,700 years something I don't
think anyone else could do keep in mind
not only did he count he counted the
seconds precisely something that is very
hard to do on its own even up to one
minute let alone 3,700 years then he
converted those precise seconds into
precise years and days accounting for
leap years and everything else so yeah
he's insanely smart but what makes him
even better is that he's like Albert
Einstein crossed with an insanely
charismatic rock star not only does he
have scientific knowledge
it also excites him to no end it makes
his life exhilarating I feel like I
would have enjoyed science class much
more in elementary school if I had sanku
as a role model back then another epic
cycle moment is when Tsukasa takes
usually huh hostage he wants sanku and
his scientific knowledge to be a race
from this world but not before sank who
gives him the formula for restoring
people Tsukasa wants to create a new and
ideal world without the corruption of
the old civilized world
he's like a stone-age Kira in that sense
like Kira he also doesn't have real
friends that can be used as hostages
while cenk who has tied you and by
extension you Surya who can be used as
bargaining chips for that reason Tsukasa
thinks that his victory against sanku is
assured he tells sanku to tell him the
recipe for the reviving formula or he'll
kill usually huh so it seems like sanku
has two options here keep the secret
the reviving formula and watch usually
ha die or tell the secret if he tells
the secret he will no longer serve any
purpose for Tsukasa
so he'll be killed instead of usury ha
at the face of it it seems like a
lose-lose situation
Zankou decides to reveal the formula to
save usury ha and then su casa gives him
one more chance he offers to let him
live if sanku promises to turn his back
on science psycho can easily lie as he
points out but he says that he won't do
that
and then Tsukasa gives him a mortal
wound the fight between brains and brawn
seems to be over and in this stone world
brawn has won it seems like Tsukasa has
gotten everything he wanted oh except
sanku was actually several steps ahead
of Tsukasa the whole time and in truth
sanku is the one who got everything he
wanted previously cenk who noticed the
restoration abilities under the
petrification process he had some of the
stone still left on the back of his head
he regularly touched the back of his
head in a way where ty drew and use
levitra would notice it was a clue tide
you knew him well and he knew that he
never used to do that that is how they
thought to look at the back of his head
and figure out that he wasn't completely
d petrified so they poured some of the
reviving formula on him and he came back
to life just as planned
he used his intelligence to resurrect
himself after being killed
not even L could do that not only did he
escape from tsukasa's Lulu's ultimatum
by getting away with his life and
usually has life he even gained the
invaluable advantage of tricking Tsukasa
into thinking that he had killed him as
sanku points out this gives them a great
military advantage while Tsukasa thinks
that Senko is dead
sinc who will know where to cosa is the
whole time since ty Joe and yuzu Rika
will act as spies in the meantime sanku
will find more comrades and make
scientific advancements that will help
him ultimately defeat Tsukasa these
advantageous conditions could never have
been achieved if sanku hadn't planned
out his own death so well not only was
Tsukasa sluices ultimatum circumvented
the whole ultimatum itself was part of
Sega's plan from the beginning
and rather than hurting him it served as
an important stepping stone towards the
advancement of
own plants sanku didn't just think
outside the box
he created the box and trapped his
opponent in it and it truly was
exhilarating and that is it for today's
video thank you so much for watching and
remember if we hit 4,000 likes I'm gonna
have the next installment published
within a week so if you enjoy these
videos and want to see the next one soon
make sure to smash that like button and
share this video with anyone who might
enjoy watching geniuses at their best
which to be fair should be everyone if
you still haven't be sure to subscribe
and ring that notification bell so you
actually get notified when new videos
come out for more anime greatness false
on twitter and instagram at anime uproar
a big thank you goes out to our patrons
over on patreon who help make videos
like this one possible I especially want
to thank our pro hero tier patrons the
one and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson Kings outdress angel Cruz
Steelers and Pablo Pablo and the one
tier patrons the ones who stand atop all
clans baby ray 817 f f DP Steven and
Greta allall on automatic Mac 239
makoto-kun Keylong and Enrico dames and
the patrons who transcend greatness
itself Regan Harrison Lord naksan or the
chosen few who have been acknowledged by
Lords we go himself if you enjoy our
work you can support more of it by going
over to patreon calm animals or and
becoming a patron today for as little as
$1 if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these geniuses right here and you'll
even get access to our private patron
only discord so check out
patreon.com/crashcourse
[Music]
you
[Music]